be sure to check out my second channel
called Rob explains there you can check
out videos where I explain things
outside of comic books throughout the
1920s del publications served as the
industry standard on print media led by
a syndicated series of newspaper strips
called famous funnies these publications
were the go-to source for comedy satire
and adventure but a new age was emerging
one which would force del publications
out of the limelight as a competitor
emerged with a flagship character that
would change print media forever
while the Superman that we know today
with the red Kate in the blue uniform
did not appear until Action Comics issue
number one in 1938 the origins of
Superman can be traced back to his
creation at the hands of Joe Shuster in
1933 as a telepathic villain bent on
world domination during this same year
Joe Shuster would introduce his creation
to a fellow classmate at Glanville High
School in Cleveland Ohio named Jerry
Siegel who would go on to publish
Superman in his own series titled
science fiction the advance guard of
future civilization by the following
year as the two work together
Jerry Siegel would revamp the character
going through a series of drafts which
would ultimately lead is Superman's
publication with actually comics issue
number one and his establishment of the
superhero archetype and to fill you in a
little and they're really the beginning
of it all in one night
as if it has been pod mentioned in the
past stories ideas kept coming to me and
I kept getting up again and again during
the night and just jotting down these
ideas and these scripts until very early
the next morning I dashed over to Joe's
house which is about ten blocks away I
showed him the script of Superman the
entirely new concept in which there
would be a meek mild-mannered reporter
Clark Kent Lois Lane who scorned him but
who was flipped over soon as Superman
not knowing the Superman and Clark Kent
we're wondering the same person oh you
want to stay you want to stay with your
reaction the same enthusiasm I thought
it was a terrific idea and we went right
to work right then and there you sat
down at the drawing board you've heard a
signing the way the characters yeah we
spent the entire day working on it all
afternoon and and we at the drawing
board Jerry no and no I remember that
the matter of the costuming of Superman
yeah
I remember two suggestions I made you
one that the letter s well be beyond
assess right I wasn't a skin-tight
costume to to show up his physique for
one thing and then Jerry suggested
putting on okay okay so they went the
characters in so the air would give it a
lot more action the movement may look
like he's really flying and very very
yeah you wear that all those additional
things like the boots and the belt and
the possible in the eyes of Siegel and
Shuster the 1930s were a time of social
unrest and economic turmoil for the
United States it had been four years
since the onset of the Great Depression
and while things were taking a turn for
the better
for many people the effects were still
being felt suicides robberies
homelessness and a general sense of
scarcity were still a part of American
life and with the possibility of a
second world war looming in the
background society needed someone to
look up to sending to inspire them with
hope even if only for a short time
to this end Siegel and Shuster modeled
this newest version of Superman after
three important characters that
represented the strength and resiliency
of the human spirit the first was Hugo
Danner of the famed novel gladiator
written by Philip Wiley in 1930 the
results of an experiment at the hands of
his father
Hugo Danner was born with incredible
strength but told to keep his powers
hidden a society's inability to
understand him would make him a target
of fear and ignorance the second was
Hercules the Roman name used for
Heracles the famed son of Zeus and out
mean who imbued the very essence of
courage strength and ingenuity and
finally the third inspiration for
Superman came in the form of Samson a
man of biblical origin who received
incredible strength of God and so with
their newest creation in hand Jerry
Siegel and Joe Shuster spent the next
six years trying to find a publisher
trying to find someone who would take
this new his character this Superman and
bring him to the mainstream it was
during this time that Superman was
introduced to consolidated publishing
and the hope here was that consolidated
publishing which had previously released
a series called detective Dan secret
operative issue number 48 would pave the
way for the comic-book industry and by
extension allow Jerry Siegel and Joe
Shuster to further creation but
consolidated publishing had only made
one story of detective
and had no intention of moving forward
with the series and so while they have
sent an encouraging letter to Jerry
Siegel and Joe Shuster praising their
work with educational comics United
feature syndicate and now consolidated
publishing all rejecting their idea
Shuster became fed up and destroyed all
of the pages of Superman with the
exception of the cover which was saved
from a fire by Jerry Siegel and so a
Siegel and Shuster recovered from their
disappointment and continued their
efforts to find someone willing to
publish their story of Superman another
comic book icon was emerging a Tennessee
native and writer with a penchant for
creating short stories who would develop
what many considered to be the very
first comic book
I'm Nikki wheeler-nicholson and my
grandfather was major Malcolm
wheeler-nicholson and he is important
because he was the first person to use
all original art and scripts to for
comic books so he started really the
first comic books with original art and
scripts he also hired Siegel and Shuster
he was the first publisher to see the
Superman drawings he hired Bob Kane he
hired Walt Kelly basically a lot of the
industry standards and comic books are
as a result of my grandfather he began
his career in the pulps writing
adventure stories and that's one of the
reasons that the titles of the comic
books are called adventure action
Detective Comics because they come right
out of the pulse stories a former member
of the United States cavalry and 1934
Malcolm wheeler-nicholson launched
national allied publications intended to
capitalize on the popularity of the
famous funnies comic strips Nicholson
found that Dell publications was
unwilling to take a risk on his newly
established company due to fear that his
work wouldn't sell refused him to be
left out of the fledgling market
Nicholson made history for the first
time by launching his own comic book in
the form of new fun comics number one
deviating away from the reprinted
material found in famous funnies new
find Comics number one contained a
series of comedic stories involving
characters designed by Nicholson himself
however because the concept was new and
money was slow Nicholson made history a
second time by being the first company
to offer advertising in his coming book
publications in order to offset the cost
of production while Malcolm
wheeler-nicholson would go on to launch
adventure comics as the second
publication he also discovered that
because famous funnies was selling so
well as it contained characters that the
general public was already familiar with
distributors were hesitant to invest in
his content because it had never been
tested before and their eyes famous
funnies had an established market and
Dell publications have proven itself
capable of providing content that
customers would purchase and so with
money running out fast
in virtually all doors being closed in a
face Nicholson found himself in a
partnership with a man named Harry
donenfeld as the owner and operator of
independent news while Harry donenfeld
had occasionally dipped his toe in
magazine markets independent news
largely operated as a distributor as
well saying this has his chance to
ensure the existence of new fun comics
and adventure comics as well as
introduces 3rd publication in the form
of Detective Comics Malcolm
wheeler-nicholson sacrificed a large
majority of the rights to his work in
order to allow Harry donenfeld to
provide distribution with Nicholson and
Donna Feld working together and forming
a joint company called Detective Comics
incorporated under the umbrella of
national allied publications the two
began to hire on various writers and
artists in an effort to introduce new
ideas and among the creators hired on as
part of the Detective Comics
incorporated branch where Siegel and
Shuster while their early work in
Detective Comics consisted of stories
like slam Bradley a private detective
with brains and brawn who for all
intents and purposes was a spiritual
predecessor to Batman Siegel and Shuster
also saw this as an opportunity to
attempt to introduce Superman
unfortunately because of the rapid
growth of Detective Comics Incorporated
and with the company receiving numerous
concepts written or drawn by other
aspiring creators Siegel and Shuster
Superman was quite literally thrown into
a pile and completely ignored while the
two continued their work was slain
Bradley among other creations Malcolm
wheeler-nicholson decision to engage in
business with Harry donenfeld would come
back to haunt him and the summer of 1938
donenfeld sent Nicholson on a vacation
for the purpose of brainstorming and
creating new ideas for the company
during Nicholson's vacation however
Harry donenfeld filed a lawsuit against
their Wilson for non-payment and because
Nicholson's vacation made it impossible
for him to appear in court Donnell
filled won the lawsuit by default
judgment as a result Malcolm
wheeler-nicholson was forced out of
Detective Comics Incorporated and Harry
donenfeld retained all rights to
national allied publications and his
properties including Detective Comics
incorporated as well as all of the work
produced by Nicholson himself and so
with Nicholson out of the picture and
donenfeld in control as Detective Comics
incorporated while he continued
publication and distribution for new fun
comics adventure comics and Detective
Comics he also sought to expand the
lineup of existing stories Logica fourth
series in the form of action comics but
short on material that could be provided
to meet the deadline for the launch date
Donna felt instructed Action Comics
Editor Vince Sullivan to find content
that could quickly be added to issue
number one sorting through a stack of
right ends
Vince Sullivan stumbled upon Superman
and as a result not only was he added to
the roster of stories but printed on the
front cover originally depicted as a
child sit away from a dying world by an
unnamed scientist the newborn was
discovered by two passing motorists who
took him to a local orphanage while
there he demonstrated incredible
strength and as the years passed he was
able to leap 1/8 of a mile race
tremendous weights and went faster than
an express train all due to his advanced
physiology and the fact that his race
was endowed with incredible strength
once they reach maturity with the name
Clark Kent operating as a disguise
Superman served to fight on behalf of
the common man within the pages of
Action Comics issue number one Siegel
and Shuster also developed Superman's
main love interests in the form of Lois
Lane a tough-as-nails journalist whose
name is actually a derivative of Lola
Lane one of three sisters that performed
as a 1930s singing act considered by
many to be the first lady of comics and
the quintessential damsel in distress
and truth the development of her
character was influenced by three
individuals physically Lois Lane was
designed to look like Jo Ann Carter the
future wife of Jerry Siegel who started
her modeling career after posing for a
series of drawings by Siegel while he
was working on a concept for Lois Lane
in terms of personality
Sigmund Shuster used the fictional
character of torchi Blaine a no-nonsense
reporter who did what it took to get the
story and was played by Glenda Farrell
in a series of 1930s films as well as
Elizabeth Cochran seaman the famed
photojournalist who traveled around the
world in 72 days for Siegel and Shuster
Lois Lane existing as photo reporter and
a love interest of Superman was a
combination that inspired elations
Spence and comedy among fans working
directly with Clark Kent the banter
between the two was a hallmark of their
friendship and as a love interest of
Superman Lois served to ground his
character and make him more human
despite his alien origins but as a
reporter fans always wondered if she
would ever learn that Clark Kent and
Superman were one in the same
however following the release of Action
Comics number one Harry donenfeld
considered both the character of
Superman and the concept to be
ridiculous and while he had intended for
Superman to be removed from publication
and effectively locked away his mind was
changed when as a legend goes he
approached a young boy at
extend and when he asked why the young
man was buying Action Comics issue
number one the boy replied because it's
the one that has Superman with sales of
Action Comics cementing the Superman was
here to stay the Golden Age of comics
had begun and the comic-book industry
was off to the races selling the rights
to their creation for one hundred and
thirty dollars in a contract to supply
material by 1939 the success of Superman
saw Siegel and Shuster collaborating
with the introduction of a solo series
titled Superman number 1 which ran
alongside Action Comics but differed and
that the stories of his solo series
focused largely on Superman himself
instead of including supporting
characters like Lois Lane which were
frequently seen in action comics during
the same year the Man of Steel received
his own radio show program titled The
Adventures of Superman and by 1941 the
world was met with Superman's first
animated film created by Fleischer
Studios the now infamous although
defunct animation studio based out of
New York City not always perfect for DCs
newest creation though while Superman's
success saw the introduction of heroes
like Batman two standout star of
Detective Comics and a rival that would
remain one of Superman's closest
competitors in both sales and popularity
the Golden Age of comics also saw the
introduction of characters similar to
Superman the closest of which was a hero
named Captain Marvel the 1939 brainchild
of writer Bill Parker and artist CC Beck
Captain Marvel's popularity rivaled
Superman in that while the Man of Steel
was the first superhero Captain Marvel
had summoning Superman didn't a child
with superpowers with comic books
becoming increasingly popular among
young boys the allure of Superman came
in the form of imagination and the
possibility that his readers could live
vicariously through his comics and right
the wrongs of their own lives
using the Man of Steel's fantastic
powers capitalizing on the sentiment
Fawcett comics a division of Fawcett
publications looking to cash in on the
rise of superheroes introduced Captain
Marvel as a young homeless boy named
Billy Batson who was led to a wizard
named Shazam recognizing the financial
struggles of Billy Batson as well as the
courage he displayed in the face of such
hardship the wizard bestowed Billy with
the power to become a superhero by
shouting the word Shazam because Captain
Marvel provided fans with the belief
that a child could become equal to
Superman the sales of Captain Marvel's
sword and even led to a radio show that
predated Superman's
and so recognizing the success of
Captain Marvel and that his character
appeared to be a carbon copy of Superman
DC filed a lawsuit on the grounds of
copyright infringement a case which will
go on to remain in court for over ten
years by the time the 1940s came around
Superman was cemented as a mainstay in
pop culture but at the time his stories
largely consisted of one or two issue
battles between himself and a gangster
or some small-time villain in the minds
of Siegel and Shuster in order for their
creation to have longevity outside of
this initial comic boom Superman needed
a nemesis and art villain that would
return constantly to face him however
because Superman's abilities were
largely physical with strength speed and
power his nemesis needed to be the other
half of the equation and possess a level
of intelligence that would test the Man
of Steel and push him to both his moral
and mental limits to this end Siegel and
Shuster introduced Lex Luthor in the
pages of Action Comics issue number 23
as a megalomaniac bent on world
domination and his first appearance
Luthor had amassed an army by way of
mind control and was in the midst of
pitting two unnamed European countries
against one another when Lois Lane
stumbled upon his plan sending a note
off to Superman through a soldier who
was unaffected by Lex Luthor's devices
Lois Lane was eventually rescued and Lex
Luthor was defeated testing the waters a
second time Lex Luthor returned in
Superman you should number four in 1940
but Siegel and Shuster also used this as
a way to establish Superman's moral
limits in addition to his wits with Lex
Luthor challenging Superman to a series
of tests regarding his strength speed
and durability at the conclusion
Superman threatened to throw Luthor into
his own plane cracking his skull in the
process while Luthor admitted defeat
this situation went towards a darker
nature of Superman during the Golden Age
and that he was willing to kill and in
the case where someone willingly
threatened his life or the life of
someone around him expressed a little
remorse over their deaths however as
time passed Joe Shuster xyce I began to
deteriorate but because Superman's
popularity was at a fever pitch leading
to appearances in world's finest and
other DC publications Shuster was unable
to keep up with the increased workload
in response he lost his own studio which
hired on artists such as Jack Burnley
Fred Rey Wayne boring and Alka steno all
whom would become known as some of the
most iconic artists for the Superman
title during this time however the world
was changing Germany had already invaded
Poland and World War 2 was underway with
the United States remaining neutral form
of political and social reasons
Superman's comics during the early days
of world war ii maintained his role as
fighting criminals and corrupt
politicians as well as saving the day
but after the Japanese attack on Pearl
Harbor in 1941 leading to a declaration
of war by the United States Superman
like nearly all comic book superheroes
reflected this and that his story saw a
shift from fighting on American soil to
fighting overseas while the Superman
publications never officially used terms
like Adolf Hitler or Benito Mussolini
the propaganda within his comic books
was clear
Superman supports the Allied troops and
so should you
and so by 1945 at the close of World War
two following the surrender of Japan
aboard the USS Missouri as the most
popular title DC had at the time the
Superman comics began to shift their
focus back to the United States with
Dick Grayson introduces Robin in 1940
and serving as a driving force behind
Batman's popularity among children DC
looked to incorporate this element into
the Superman mythos as a way to expand
on his character and increase sales and
so in the same year under the writing
and artistry of Siegel and Shuster DC
officially launched Superboy
appearing for the first time in more fun
comics issue number 101 because of
Superman's popularity Superboy was an
immediate hit among fans introducing
concepts like Superman's hometown of
Smallville Superboy provided fans with
the evolution of Superman and filled the
gap between his arrival on earth and his
undertaking of the Superman mantle this
combined with Superman issue number 53
in 1948 retelling his origin story by
introducing jor-el as Superman's father
meant that during a time when the
popularity of superheroes was on the
decline following the end of World War
two Superboy was actually gaining
popularity and so by 1949 he received
his own solo series athlete idled
Superboy number one
during the same year and after his
creation for the Superman radio show in
1943 under William Woolfolk fans were
met with the comic-book introduction of
kryptonite originally depicted as red in
color its first introduction into the
comic books explains that kryptonite
arrived on earth following Krypton's
destruction and served to provide a
weakness to Superman an aspect of his
character
they made him all the more relatable
which in turn fueled the flames of his
popularity in the eyes of fans it seemed
as though the publication's of Superman
were nothing short of perfect a
sentiment that would be compounded on
during the Silver Age which would see
Superman's origins revisited and answers
provided to some of his fans most
burning questions